Health Network Laboratories is a multi
regional reference lab health quartered
in Allentown Pennsylvania serving more
than 12,000 health care providers we
provide both clinical and I'm atomic
pathology services the flow cytometry
department processes an average of 150
samples per month for Leukemia and
Lymphoma amino phenotyping a few years
ago we had heard about dura clone tubes
at the Beckman Coulter user group
meeting and decided to implement them to
address two issues first our client list
was expanding to include four additional
hospitals and we needed to absorb the
new volume without adding staffing
second the technologists were beginning
to experience medical issues related to
repetitive motion from manually
pipetting an ever-increasing number of
tubes dura clone tubes are custom made
to the laboratories and specifications
liquid reagents are dried into the tubes
according to our panel configurations we
perform titration studies with all of
our current liquid reagents once we had
the volumes and delusions we provided
that information to Beckman Coulter and
pre lot of tubes were manufactured given
that we only had 25 tubes to work with
we had to be very careful when designing
our validation our normal weekly quality
control was run for the duration of the
study which took four weeks during that
time we ran 21 samples approximately
half of which were normal and half were
abnormal all sample types were included
bone marrow peripheral blood tissues and
fluids and we made sure to include the
most common conditions acute acute and
chronic leukemias of both lymphoid and
myeloid lineage --is data analysis was
performed and included both the
percentage of positive cells and the
staining intensity for each marker on
each cell type in no case did the
staining intensity vary more than one
level between the liquid reagents and
the dura clone tubes which is equivalent
to the variability cap allows on their
proficiency surveys the percentages were
graded against our laboratories
allowable coefficient of variation and
matched greater than 98% of the time the
interpretation from the flow data and
the final interpretation from the
pathologist were also evaluated and were
consistent 100% of the time previously
it took a technologist 68 minutes to
process a sample and pipette the
liquid reagents for our standard
Leukemia Lymphoma panel with the dura
clone tubes that time has been decreased
to twenty nine minutes we have been
successful in absorbing the new hospital
volumes without an increase in staffing
and estimate our capacity has been
increased by approximately 75% with the
implementation of the dura clone tubes
you
all right so that was